foreign
Workforce by 18
000 jobs
meta expands corporate layoffs to 11 000
and deems 2023 the year of efficiency
Google lays off 12 000 employees
by email
the business world and the economy right
here in Silicon Valley is very different
from the one that we saw just one year
ago
we're moving from a time of abundant
seemingly free venture capital for tech
companies
and into a recession with a new and
intense focus on operating efficiently
if you're leading a team or managing a
business right now it can feel a bit
like entering the wartime workplace
companies are just trying to make it out
the other side alive
and in Wartime it's very easy to focus
on achieving necessary outcomes at all
costs
by moving fast and breaking things
by being paranoid instead of being
trusting
and by putting relationships aside
because hey there are fires that have to
be put out
but I'm here to tell you that a
relationship first approach to
leadership is part of how we will make
it through the current downturn
so when we head out into the business
world to lead our own organizations to
run our own teams I think it's time for
us to Define workplace culture instead
of letting the current moment Define it
for us
it's really tempting to put
relationships aside to de-prioritize
them and to focus only on the bottom
line but it's in Hard Times Like These
that we need people the most
business is built on relationships
relationships rooted in trust that spur
collaboration and drive the performance
we need to make it through hard times
I learned this lesson myself for the
first time when I was working with my
dear friend and former client Lynn
together we had just under five months
to do what felt like a whole Year's
worth of work building a mini MBA
program for her company's top 200
executives
it was really daunting at first figuring
out exactly what they needed to know
about business and then pack it into a
program that felt fun cohesive engaging
one afternoon after our working session
the conversation that Lynn and I had
turned to our families and to holiday
traditions and I told Lynn about the
Brandy Alexander
now for those of you who've never tried
an Alexander before it's made in the
blender by combining Spanish Brandy
chocolate liqueur heavy cream half and
half and a giant scoop of vanilla ice
cream on top
mix it all together and you have a
creamy Rich delicious treat
telling Lynn about the Alexander
surfaced some unexpected Common Ground
she is also a big fan of Brandy
Alexander's
they're a traditional cocktail in her
home state of Wisconsin
but this is about way more than an
alcoholic milkshake
when I told Lynn about my family and
about myself I created the opportunity
for her to share more of herself with me
it's part of how we built a trusting
connection
when I told her who I was she
reciprocated
she told me about her relationship with
her grandchildren about the time she
spends hunting with her husband at their
holiday cabin
and even about the death of their son
whose bedroom she's maintained since the
time of his passing
because we built a trusting connection
personally
when we went to work it was really easy
for Lynn and me to just get creative
with each other to bounce ideas off of
one another without fear of judgment
so after another afternoon working
session
we looked at each other
what if the program revolved around a
fictional coffee shop
a year later when our program was
recognized with a number of awards
the fictional coffee shop idea was
recognized as one of the key reasons why
we won
it was because of the trusting personal
connection we built that our working
relationship flourished allowing us to
achieve what before had seemed almost
impossible
now contrary to what some people might
tell you the wartime workplace needs
relationships The Trenches would be
awfully lonely without them
and research from McKinsey has shown
that 40 percent of an employee's
satisfaction is driven by the
relationships they have at work
the single most important relationship
they have is the one they have with
their manager
so people will see you a manager as the
single most important influence on their
happiness in the workplace
relationships are part of how you will
get the best out of other people
especially when going through hard times
now
I know what you're thinking
he really loves this relationship first
approach to leadership thing he took
touchy feely at Stanford GSB
but trust me I have seen the benefits of
this approach myself
about three and a half years ago I was
asked to be the dedicated manager to
Sasha an associate from Moscow who had
relocated to join my team based in New
York
she was a star performer in her home
country
but soon after her arrival her
performance started to plummet and none
of us could quite figure out why
so one afternoon
I took her out for a coffee and I told
her about myself
about my life in Manhattan's East
Village
about my connections to extended family
members that inspired me to move to New
York in the first place
and when I told Sasha who I was her eyes
lit up
she not only told me about where she
came from
but also about the challenges she had
been facing in the United States more
recently
how hard it was to express herself in a
language that was not her mother tongue
which made her sound unintentionally
very Brusque
how unnerving it was
to just pack up her life in a few
suitcases and move halfway across the
world with not a single family member
around
and the struggle of doing all the work
that we were expecting her to do
with the additional asks from senior
colleagues back in Russia that
unbeknownst to me or to any leaders in
the U.S were still landing on her plate
because Sasha trusted me
to tell me what was really going on
we could understand what the issues were
and then start to approach them and
address them together
before big meetings and when we were
working on important documents we
started sitting together reviewing her
language choices and pinpointing
possible improvements
and we even helped her develop a
strategy to start to push back on some
of those requests for additional work
and soon after we put these Solutions
into action
Sasha's performance started to rise
again
her natural talents became clear to many
of us
and during the pandemic she became our
go-to associate for structuring and
running big complex quantitative
analyzes
and she even upskilled a number of her
colleagues on how to do the same
so again
sharing creates Trust
trust builds relationships and
relationships drive performance
so often in business there are parts of
ourselves that we hide
because we're told to just keep the
personal and the professional separate
because we're scared
of being vulnerable and being judged
but when we hide we lose the opportunity
to form the Deep trusting connections
that are so key to doing great work
so when you head back to the office I
encourage you to reflect
what's one piece of yourself that you've
been holding back
and that you now want to bring into work
we don't know how long the current
downturn May last
but I believe that with a relationship
first approach to leadership we will
equip all of our teams to win exactly
when it matters the most
thank you
foreign